[Music]
all right people we are live on the
YouTube I've got the lobster and I've
got the hair it sounds like some sort of
70s guys that could that be a rock band
or is that like it could be some kind of
violent flick or a mafia movie or
violent rock band a violent rock man
yeah all right I've wanted to get you
guys together you two have never been
seen on camera before I think that's
true as far as you know I did appear in
front of Jordan but we never intersected
onstage at the Masonic when you decided
I should open when you mean harmonica
harmonica solo out of all the same
moments that we've had in the last two
months would you say that bringing Eric
Weinstein mathematician out on stage at
the Masonic to play the harmonica and
have 3,000 people give him a standing
ovation would that be the time yeah that
was good that was good it worked really
well too because he turned out he
actually could play the harmonica yeah
she's a good thing if you're going to
try it in front of 3,000 people I'd do
that first for me I didn't play in front
of a smaller crowd before that so I was
uh it was a bit of a it was pretty sweet
all right so good night yeah all right I
want to cover a hundred percent of new
stuff okay for the next two hours
there's a bunch of stuff obviously that
we've been hitting on on tour and some
things that we've been sort of catching
up on as this has all been going on so I
thought the place to start I think would
be something that I've been starting a
lot of the shows with when I go out
there and I do a little intro and I get
everybody going and warming up for for
Jordan the idea that we're starting to
win and when I've been saying win
there's a feeling in the crowd of like
whoa maybe all of this madness that
we've all been talking about for all
these years may be enough people have
woken up now that there is something
shifting so I've brought that up up a
bunch and you've sort of picked up on it
on a couple of shows and talked about
why winning isn't necessarily the way we
should view this or what winning
actually is so I thought that would be a
good place to to kick us off here well
it's like it's more what winning
actually is you know because one of the
things that has to be contended with in
the current situation is that
especially in the United States but also
in the rest of the Western world there's
a political divide Americans have been
voting 50% Republican and 50% Democrat
for for elections pretty much split
right down the middle and they're keep
there can't be any final victory by one
side over the other because everyone has
to live together so the victory is how
can we continue to live together
peacefully and productively and and and
and we have to figure out the pathway
forward to that but then I think there's
another kind of victory that it's deeper
than that that's on the horizon which is
that I think the narrative that
underlies our culture as a whole has to
shift and I started to think about this
when I was working for a UN committee
about five years ago I worked on a
committee on sustainability for the
secretary-general and I had a chance
with the people that I was working for
and within Canada to rewrite the
underlying narrative because it was very
pessimistic it was a real Cold War
narrative North against South and
capitalists against socialists and doom
and gloom on the horizon and it seemed
to me to be outdated really by about 40
years and I started to read a lot of the
economic development and ecology
literature and mostly what I found was
that things are getting better globally
so fast and on so many different
dimensions that it's almost
inconceivable and yet no one seems to
know that and in the aftermath of that
there's been about six books published
in the last five years that like
Pinker's book right but but but by no
means that's by no means the only book
detailing out a revolution in living
standard progress and and ecological
progress for that matter around the
world so I think there's two victories
to be held here to be had here one is to
pull us everyone out of the pessimistic
apocalyptic Cold War narrative that
enveloped us for four or five decades
and to notice that the future could
actually be bright if we were careful
and the second is to make sure that the
political dialogue in the West doesn't
polarize to the degree that we start
doing things that are fatally stupid
yeah all right so let's talk about the
second part first because I think that's
where we've really been for
seeing the political part so it's
interesting to note this fifty-fifty
divides I don't think that's a reason I
guess I have a strongly different take
and maybe it's the same we'll have to
figure that out to me the 50/50 mark is
going to more or less hold as long as
these two parties can calculate what's
the maximum they can what with the
minimum they have to give up to win an
election and so the key issue is what is
the 50/50 composition look like and
unfortunately what it keeps looking like
is the two parties becoming more and
more nightmarish in my mind and less
trustworthy so we the fifty-fifty
continues to hold but what it represents
is attention attention increases is
getting much worse so the key issue is
that those of us who are sort of Center
I mean I don't love the left-right
spectrum but let's just use it as
shorthand that the center left and the
center right have to see each other as
our natural allies and the center left
has to clean house and get rid of the
nutty left and the center right has to
get rid of the far right and that's the
optimistic scenario I think winning is
incredibly important okay well that's a
good interesting way of conceptualizing
it let me go a little bit further sure I
think that we have to stop being
apologetic about winning and what
winning means winning means that the
advance guard of the radical Center has
to make this a safe and habitable space
again and so in order to do that and the
reason I you know try to focus mostly
most of my negative energy on the left
is is that it's my responsibility to
clean house on the radical bad
progressive movement that is almost
certainly going to fuel the far-right
mmm it's not efficient for me to go
after the far-right because I mean if of
course I'm gonna be anti-nazi and it's
you skinhead right but well we've we've
talked about that a lot too because when
we do the events you know you all these
hit pieces that come out and we'll talk
a little bit about that well when they
say that your audience is all these
angry white men and all of this nonsense
which every night it is proven to be
it's like yeah you address that every
night talking about the bad identity
politics of the right but it's not
something that well believe the thing
that's strange and that ties in to what
what you're saying as well is that it
isn't obvious to me who the dangerous
right are you know it's obvious to me
who the dangerous laughte are because
they occupy the universities but it's
not just the universities this isn't I
mean this is so miss thunk if you will
that we have to really break the frame
and and re weave it so the journalists
keep saying oh you guys are focusing on
a tiny problem afflicting a few
universities that mostly nobody's ever
heard of yeah that's definitely not true
well the first thing is is that it
deflects the problem from the number one
problem isn't the universities its
journalism and so the idea is that the
journalists are saying you guys are
complaining about this small story in
the universities like no you're getting
it wrong we're complaining about the
number one story which is the sense
making apparatus having gone haywire and
if you think about these journalists
that we're now dealing with as like the
hermit crabs that have crawled into the
shells that we used to know right so
whether CNN or NPR or National Review or
whatever these structures are it's a
different group of hermit crabs the
shells are the same and the great danger
is is that if you recognize the font at
the top of the LA Times in the New York
Times you think you're getting the same
product but the product has become
radically different and there was a
problem back then I'm not saying that
there wasn't and you know of course the
issue is that when we criticize
journalists now they think we are
criticizing journalism far from it we
are praying for journals right we're
trying to feel ugly and the idea is is
that we are fighting this thing where
they've got their fingers so clearly on
the scale that everything is being
tipped and what you're getting is a more
distorted reality there's some point at
which and we have to talk about what
happened with I don't know how to
pronounce the best yet regenexx and
medicine right the idea that doctors are
creating a created a huge amount of the
harm Don found in hospitals
well many lawyers are the fourth leading
cause of death
right so now we have to talk not about
yet regenexx which is the you know that
which originates from the healers but
journey genex which is what is the harm
done to the truth by journalists and
that is so I have a technological slant
on that to some degree because one of
the things that I think is happening
because I've watched large organizations
degenerate because I've worked as a
consultant for a lot of years now it's
really interesting to see how fast a
large organization that you think is
semi-permanent can disintegrate it can
happen while certainly within the span
of a couple of years and sometimes a lot
faster he's not yes well and I think one
of the things that seems to be happening
to me is that as television dies under
the weight of YouTube primarily but
let's say online video and perhaps also
podcasts is that the the remaining
journalists the hermit crabs who occupy
the old shells which is a good way of
thinking about it get increasingly
desperate for attention and so they're
pushed by economic pressure in some
sense and situational pressure to
exaggerate the danger it's like and it's
a clickbait phenomena essentially and it
seems to me to be akin to what's
happened with with reports on the crime
rate so you know over the last 25 years
the five major indices of violent crime
have declined by 50 percent which is
absolutely sin in the United States
staggering decrease but the rate of
reporting of violent crime has gone up
substantially and so people think that
things are more dangerous now than they
were even though they're safer now than
they have been since the early 60s and
they were safer then than they'd ever
been in history so I think one of the
things and it's interesting to think
about the technological forces driving
this because YouTube and podcasts do
pose a fatal threat I would say
certainly to to to television and so it
makes sense to me that as the
journalists become less professional and
less in demand and their messages as as
is chasing a diminishing audience that
they're going to get noisier and noisier
about what's going on and the trick for
everyone else who's being immersed in
that is to stay sane and sensible while
the death throes play themselves out so
wouldn't you
actually think though that more of them
would start seeing this I mean what we
now see so clearly and that more of them
would be jumping ship or is that old
shell so tainted or corroded that
getting out of that thing well it's
almost impossible to do with systems of
selective pressure so Jordan raises an
excellent point that the dying throes of
an institution tend to be its most
violent because it's in go-for-broke
mode and it's not worrying about
tomorrow it's worrying about maybe serve
up you know buying another month or two
or right what right right there's
another issue of course which is that
the format's are set so that your news
comes to you in a form that is more or
less the same every day and so you know
how to consume it and so everybody
listens to NPR has a pre grooved
template in their brain I'm gonna get
the top stories at the top of the hour
then they're gonna be this many pieces
and they'll be like a feel-good story
and so you know exactly what you're
going to get and like here I don't know
what we're gonna maybe Jordan and I are
gonna come to blows I'm gonna we're
hoping you've got to change the drink
but but the other thing that is is that
in the system of selective pressures as
the business model fails you have a
fascinating phenomenon which people who
are willing to accept strange blends of
payment
so lower financial payment and security
job security but higher psychic payment
stemming from the idea that they are
crusading mm-hmm are going to start to
dominate so you're seeing many more
people who are willing to substitute
activism and the sense that they are
protagonists in a great story about the
resistance let's say yeah so that that
actually becomes more and more necessary
as the stability and and the viability
of the system degenerates right if you
could offer you know two hundred
thousand dollar salaries to good
reporters in short order so that they
could start families and buy homes and
have an easier life like one of the
things that you need to do is you need
to pay people more if you're unhappy
with them and this I think about
professors actually well sociology
professors have their salaries tripled
they'd be a lot less radically I learned
this from
New Orleans Police Department where at
some point they had corruption where
people were ordering mob style hits over
police radio and I think what happened
was that the new police chief came in he
said the first thing he did was raise
salaries mm-hmm and the idea being that
you have to have skin in the game thanks
to the see until evidence that phrases
proliferated thanks to the scene
wherever you are and you need to give
people something to defend and so it's
very important to pay the people that we
are decrying all the time yes your money
and say everybody who's listening should
go online and donate to quill its
patreon page yeah great words and
Colette is doing great well I'm saying
that we should we should try to figure
out how to get Vox more money as well
mm-hmm and we should try to figure out
how to get slate and salon and all of
these things so that you can afford to
pay people in ways in which they don't
have to take a large portion of their
payment as psychic gratification from
having felled imaginary dragon but just
to be clear there when you're saying
that you're not saying that the current
people who have screwed this whole thing
up deserve more money well you're gonna
find I can find I have a very strange
position on this which is in you know my
friend Peter Thiel and I talk about this
all the time his model is is that you
know at some level when the economy
isn't working people engage in this kind
of nonsensical you know fratricide of a
type and my point is slightly different
which is this this bad nature is always
there but it's like it a compromised
immune system when you when the economy
starts to fail you start to become aware
of all of the pathogens in the world
because it can't fight them off and so
it's it's very much the issue that if
you're the guy with compromised immune
system you're the only one aware of all
the pathogens in the world and so at the
moment our collective economic immunity
system is failing and I actually a much
more pessimistic than you are Jordan I
see lots of reasons to be happy about
the decrease in violence but you know
one of the problems with the accounting
in these theories is is that the sword
of Damocles that hangs over
heads you know his gana is has gotten
quite large and the number of threads
holding it up seemed very few in number
and so you have to do the potential
energy accounting as well as the
realized violence and also understanding
that the nature of income inequality and
differential access to financial markets
and technology is creating a lot of very
justifiable concern that the post-world
War two stability is constantly in
jeopardy and if we don't I I personally
think we should think about once every
five years above-ground nuclear test to
remind ourselves of what it is that
we've pushed underground and we haven't
seen for years because we are engaged in
some kind of magical thinking that the
world is fairly stable and that can turn
on a dime so what kind of out do you
think we could for this crew of
journalists that we're talking about
that we want to be doing more journalism
we don't want them to be attacked or any
of those things of course what is the
out so that I get it you can give me you
could fund them in a way that gives them
a little more breathing room but one of
the things that I'm seeing when we're on
tour is be everyone that comes up to me
after says well you just gave us a
little room - yeah I'm think yeah so is
there a way we instead of beating these
journalists instead of getting the wind
where you crush them so that they're
losers what's the way that we can give
them maybe a little well I mean it's
it's sort of standard behavioral
practice in some senses this is
something that was established by
Skinner a long while back even though he
used threatened punishment as ways of
altering the behavior of his
experimental animals he also used reward
but rewards a lot harder to use because
what you have to do is you have to watch
very carefully and then when you see an
increment in the behavior that you want
to want to promote you have to reward it
but it requires a tremendous amount of
attention and subtle attention and and
so one of the things that we can
certainly do and that I've been trying
to do to some degree with my twitter
account is to is to distribute good news
good credible news and good journalism
when I see it which is Martley why I
started to get engaged say with Colette
because I think they're doing a credible
job but
one possibility is to distribute those
pieces that seem to be increasingly
reasonable and another is to also leap
to the defense of people when they're
taken out as individuals and because one
of the things that's happening now is
that when an individual stands up and
says something especially that annoys
the radical left is that they tend to
get mobbed and taken out and that's a
bad thing it would be good if we could
figure out ways of defending people
against that yeah I mean brett has been
defended to some degree by the emergence
of this group of people that that eric
has been describing as the intellectual
dark web yeah and so there's some
strength in numbers there that might be
usefully applied can you just quickly
talk about that just on the personal
level cuz I think one of the most moving
things that I've heard on this show is
when I had you on and I think you I
think it was with Brett and you said
that standing with him was really one of
the most validating things that you've
ever done in your life and it's such an
example of what you've been talking
about on the tour that if you want to
fix the world then fix yourself a little
bit and then the more that you do that
you might start affecting things around
you and I think that that's by helping
your brother in this case you you were
sort of helping the world well yeah that
that's nice but I the returns to me were
high and has nothing to do with follower
counts on Twitter or anything like
really I don't think the you know we
should talk about positive models of
masculinity and standing shoulder to
shoulder with somebody in a fight is an
important part of what it means to be
complete in a masculine sense and I
think that we are all incentivized by
shows you know like survivor or you know
I think the last contestant or whatever
all this stuff and you know they do the
promos with the contestants on these
shows like I'm not here to make friends
I'm here to win you know okay well what
is that that's corporate America
teaching us how to stab everyone else in
the back on your way to the top which
actually doesn't work very well by
doesn't work
all right or not for that long yeah if
you can't follow you can't lead you know
can't make friends with you can't make
your friends you're you're alone and
vulnerable right yeah right you know I
mean maybe Stalin if you're a god to the
is the best example of a really
malignant person who managed to kill
everybody including I think his wife
mmm-hmm
but it's very rare than anybody you know
it does that really what what these
things are because you're after
remembered that fragging is a
possibility the the lowest person in
your organization can take you down if
they're not happy
right right right and so I think that
what people need to understand is is
that there is this lost art of standing
with somebody that you don't 100% agree
with who says things that I you know
there are definitely things you do on
stage that I'm not comfortable with but
if somebody comes to attack you
fundamentally I know that all of those
points I can bring up to you you know
face to face I assume it's true in
Reverse and so this idea of standing
with people you know Dave you've been
going down a libertarian path that I'm
uncomfortable with often but somebody
says you know we hash it out publicly
and privately publicly and privately and
so and there's stuff I'll do privately
with you that I won't do publicly
because I think that it is important to
learn how to stand in units because
otherwise you just get picked on and
this is you know there's a topic that I
want to bring up a little bit later
which is what do I think the IDW since
you've discussed it gets wrong and one
thing I think we get wrong is is that
the tribalism that we keep seeing is so
toxic that we decide that we are anti
tribal mm-hmm it's not the right model
you want to be adaptively tribal and
adaptively individualistic right these
things matter groups matter groups have
specialized knowledge very often you
know I my group has certain stuff your
group has a different we engage in trade
it is important to understand that
tribalism can be adaptive and so it's
very troubling to me that the the
dumbest voices on the other side are
causing us to overreact to
simplistically so standing with my
brother yeah there's a reason that you
know people say he's like a brother to
me because it means that
you will put yourself at great risk and
you know I've taken a lot of slings and
arrows for for Brett and there's a
pleasure in it I'm not gonna say that it
didn't lead to sleepless nights and that
I don't worry about friends that I've
lost but it's also you know in some
sense good to know and people respond
positively because it's in our it's in
our makeup to say well that guy didn't
run from a fight
so do we basically have to just mat
model it out for people in our behavior
so for example when the New York Times
piece came out on you about three weeks
ago the enforced monogamy you know piece
now the author of it I I'm not even
gonna mention her name but if you want
it you can go ahead she sat in the
greenroom with us I think on the first
night in Toronto she was all smiles oh
Emily you even said to me how much you
liked her and you introduced me to her
and we were you know we were chatting
she seemed perfectly pleasant and lovely
and then of course this piece comes out
it implies that you're for forced
monogamy which is which money you just
explained that real quick just do it do
a one-man well the irritation what you
were the implication was and and and to
the degree that this has been let's say
exaggerated in the aftermath of the
piece the implication was that I was
promoting the idea that you know
perfectly innocent women would be lined
up by the state and distributed on mass
to undeserving males they wouldn't be
violent we've only done that at one show
right yeah well exactly exactly it's and
it did it didn't go that so so and and
that was quite curious because that part
of the conversation I had with the
journalist lasted probably two minutes
out of what was essentially a two-day
interview and it was obviously something
that triggered her imagination in in the
sense that she saw that she could use it
for for I don't know for political
purposes or something like that in the
piece but it was so pulp ibly absurd
because the and I would say amateurish
in some sense as well because the
position that she accused me of holding
a I didn't hold so that that's the first
problem be no one holds like if you're
going to try to pillory someone in a
manner that's at least vaguely
believable you should accuse them of
holding a view that at least some person
has held at some point right and no one
has ever held that view and then the
other thing that was quite
off-putting let's say is that she's not
stupid
she knew perfectly well what I meant by
enforced monogamy
by the term it's an anthropological term
it's been used for a hundred years and
the idea that polygamous societies which
would be the contrast say to monogamous
societies the idea that they're more
violent is no one disputes that yeah
it's it's like a it's an anthropological
sociological and psychological truism
and it's also one that's been it's not
like the left has been promoting
polygamy you know so so it was it was
well that the the the article surprised
me to say the least yeah but you made an
interesting move after that which ties
this all together because you did a
little checking on the phrase in in the
archives of the New York Times well the
whole point to me was if I could take
Jordan out of the equation and I could
make it into the New York Times
wrestling with itself I was pretty sure
that the New York Times would have some
record of having used the phrase
enforced monogamy
at some point and so I went to the
search engine and I put in quote
enforced monogamy close quote and sure
enough there were two relatively recent
references within the last 20 25 years
both of them positive one I believe
coming out of evolutionary theory in
Drosophila where it's a less common term
in evolutionary theory but it has leaked
into the evolutionary literature and the
other one coming from Afghanistan where
you have polygamous marriage and that
leaves too many violent young men with
nothing to do and that can be useful if
your conquest in other lands say well
you have no wife here but there's a
there's a territory over there and this
is exactly you know the New York Times
was celebrating the idea that in a
culture that was that that that stage in
its evolution
enforcement agha me was something that
went hand in hand with women's rights
because of course having the classing
aren't you having fewer violent men with
no romantic prospects is in general good
for the safety of women and so the whole
thing which is actually my point I know
but the point was can i take Jordan out
of it and say the New York Times is
wrestling with itself and not fairly and
this is the great dangers that that
finger is on the scale now the other
thing is is that that particular
journalist first met was talking with
Brett well before talking with you and
then Brett sent this journalist to me
and by the way I don't think that we
should not talk about the name of the
journalist since the journalist is
certainly using your name and the idea
so it's Nellie Bowles and right right I
found her engaging charming very quick
intelligent the thing that I didn't
appreciate and they got fairly far into
my discussion with her and I was off the
record is you know she began with the
gambit well of course I'm gonna be
running your tweet on James d'amour
which you know went viral and was widely
misinterpreted and again in a deliberate
fashion which my tweet was responding to
somebody saying you know if human
resources that somebody else is from
Google tweeted if human resources won't
do something about this then you know
they're gonna have trouble on their
hands and it's like okay you're telling
people to run to human resources because
James d'amour is looking at Big Five
psychometrics for personality and asking
the question how do we increase the
accessibility of Google to female coders
and whether you agree with his technique
or not I think that that was clearly his
point so the idea is I'm going to bring
up this tweet that has been widely
mischaracterized of yours Eric and you
know what we became clear was she had
the idea that she wanted to find the
men's rights activist community yeah and
you know she said something about well
you're MRA mm-hmm and I didn't even know
what that meant so I said NRA that was
national right right and she's like you
know men's rights activist I said what
and so we had this well that was just
you being disingenuous because of course
you know what men rights activists are
yeah but the point would be you know
it's like you you believe in human
rights yes well you know men are human
so you believe in men's rights and you
believe that one should be active you
know so you know at some level it's a
reserved
term for people who are very often kind
of veering a spectrum of people who are
talking about bad aspects of family you
know law versus people who are downright
misogynist right right and I was just
aghast which is like why are you trying
to shoehorn me into this pre-existing
thing well that's the question well this
is the motivation for the for the
shoehorning and well this is so this is
the big issue coming you know it's like
all the threads let me let me get back
to what we don't understand is is that
they've invested in all of this
cognitive Lego right so they've you know
the equity or toxic masculinity or when
it's a privilege whatever these things
are and so everything in high
dimensional space gets shoved into this
completely inappropriate kind of
cognitively furthermore the format of
these things like I recently got asked
to do a bit on a on a show on television
on an established network and they said
you know we're really blowing it out
we've we've got the message that this
new form of long-form interview is the
wave of the future it's like well how
much am I gonna get yeah we might go
from five to eight minutes right right
the idea is like say hello in fact but
this is the point right it's like I have
access to three hours when I want it
great like well that's insane right like
they can't move that much and so partly
why the format's dying because and it's
also I think one of the reasons that we
think we're stupider than we are
I like losing learn a lot are including
our audience is that you know because TV
one of the things I have noticed about
television in general is that it's
predicated on the presumption that the
audience is stupid but if you have to
force everything through a channel whose
maximum dimension is six minutes right
then everyone's going to look was a
different thing this is if you think
about what happened where television
went from being the dumb medium to the
incredibly smart medium when you went
from TV dramas of a half an hour maybe
an hour in length to many many shows
over a season developing characters at a
level that a fulfill
can't touch that literature approaches
right
right right so the idea is that in the
Sopranos are Mad Men or Game of Thrones
people are following incredibly
difficult and rich plots and you have to
go back to this old adage which nobody
ever lost a dime under estimating the
intelligence of the American people well
that's only true if you don't understand
opportunity costs because people have
been losing dimes but millions by not
understanding that anyone who can follow
Game of Thrones right how is it that
this thing that we're about to do I have
no idea what you know we'll just have a
conversation there's gonna be over a
hundred thousand views of this thing I
think very quickly yeah III got one
video on my channel of any substance one
video it's got nearly sixty thousand
views people are hungry for this thing
they're being starved yes and what they
don't understand in the regular media is
is that their format is killing them and
I you know well this is something we
really we really have to pay attention
to because a tremendous amount of what's
going on is the consequence you know you
said that a complex reality is being
shoveled into a tiny dimensional space
and so there's some ideological reasons
for that but I think some of that is
being fed by the channels of the media
because it's a lot easier to take a
complex situation like that and shovel
it into a pre-existing a priori
interpretive space because everyone
already understands it so if you've only
got a few minutes then there's a bunch
of things that you don't have to explain
because you're just telling the same old
story because what what we also don't
grasp is that we don't file flight plans
like you're having me on the show you
don't know what what I'm gonna say you
don't know what my positions are on
immigration you don't know what my
positions are an abortion we've never
gotten to that I don't think and I was
actually thinking that about both of you
I don't think we've ever discussed it we
can't get in which we can but what the
the way this commentariat works and I've
been waking up to the idea that this
layer even exists because I didn't think
about it too much is that mostly these
people have consistent takes that is
their counted upon to take a complicated
reality and you know give us the Tom
Friedman point give us the
give us the paul krugman point you know
give us the Ezra Klein view and you're
thinking well why is there a sort of
regular consistent view on these things
like I've watched Jordan I've watched
you change your mind in real time as
somebody makes a good argument and it's
a little bit painful because somebody
was listening to you and then they say
well how do I have faith in your
argument that my answer is how do you
faith in any of this stuff I all of this
stuff can reverses won't you have more
faith if somebody can reverse themselves
yeah I'm thinking about the the the
baking a cake for a gay couple yes yes
well look what happened good when we'll
get back to Nellie Bowles because I want
to return to that but you know one of
the things that was really interesting
to watch in Vancouver I just had two
discussions with Sam Harris and the the
discussion was set up from a promotional
perspective by a promoter who was doing
his job as a kind of a combat situation
right there was going to be a victory it
would be Sam or me and in the final
analysis versus it right and so but what
happened was that Sam and I actually had
a discussion where we were trying to lay
out our points to understand each
other's points and we set this up what
was one of Bret's ideas actually cuz
Brett your brother Moulton moderated
when the second discussion opened what
he had us do was summarize each other's
arguments so I put forth Sam's arguments
in the strongest possible terms Stillman
he did the same and that worked that
worked just fine by the way but what was
so interesting was the audience would
have settled for a debate that
culminated in the victory of one of us
over the other but instead what happened
was they got engaged in a discussion
that we had both designed to push both
of our capabilities of thinking farther
along and so and we weren't sure if that
would work because we weren't sure if we
could talk but it turned out that we
could and partly thanks to Brett's help
and then the original format was we were
going to talk for an hour for the first
one and then we're gonna open it up to
Q&A but the discussion got very intense
and I would have I likened it to
approximate level of a pretty good PhD
defense you know if you're if you have a
good student who's who's defending and
you know they know the literature you
can really go after them because it
gives them a chance to show their
mastery right so be a real
thing for them and so it was like a dual
PhD defense dua L&D UEL at the same time
but the audience was right there with us
right and then at the end of the hour
brett asked them should we switch to the
QA or should we continue the discussion
because we're in the middle of something
and overwhelmingly the sentiment was
continue the discussion and so we did
model the process of I wouldn't say
respectful dialogue because first of all
that's a cliche and second of all that
wasn't what this was what we were doing
was actually engaging in the process of
trying to make both of us smarter than
we were and and people are in for that
they're there they're on board for that
and they would they would prefer that to
the cheap victory by all appearances so
what do you think that says then if that
the audience that was there and from
what I can see with our audiences that
they care more about unlocking some
truths than they do about the victory
when we live in a time where everyone
wants to dunk on everybody constantly
and keep seeing the phrase pop up people
get you dunk dhaniya mm-hmm that's
nobody wants it but they keep shuttling
something nobody wants it I mean well
it's better than being bored and it's
better than stasis and it's better than
capitulation but it's not as good as
what could be if you got what was
optimal when I see this with my own
videos people keep chopping them up and
say you know Petersen demolishes you
know and obviously that's clickbait but
that was also one of the things that
made me think about the degeneracy
degeneration of journalism per se into
clickbait I mean that's emerging
spontaneously on YouTube as a method for
attracting attention yeah and these
people as they get more desperate as
their as their modality dies then it's
not surprising that they that they turn
to their oversimplifications for the
reasons you outlined but also to attract
attention real quick is it possible that
it worked for a while that that sort of
exposure and and clickbait nonsense made
sense sort of at the beginning of the
internet because we were also stuck in
the in the old structures that we needed
something to really wake us up but now
we're sort of past that you don't think
so that we don't think we're past it
enough that it doesn't work
if you want to avoid having me as a
guest in the future here's one of the
standard moves that I'm a stop talking
about what's good and bad and start
putting the phrase adaptive and
maladaptive in front of different
modalities we like adaptive dumb dunking
I've got this problem with this guy Noah
Smith I don't know what is his problem
as he's an economist he's engaging he's
relatively charming he's got a position
on immigration where he just loves
immigration there's nothing you can't
have too much immigration immigration is
just the best thing in the world maybe
it has some problems in some sector but
in general it's a free lunch and I've
done work on this to try to show no it's
a much more complicated situation and
behind the scenes it's being abused as
has nothing to do with immigrants it's
Americans transferring wealth into their
own pockets from other Americans using
immigrants we can get into this later
I have tried I've had lunch with the guy
I've shown in my papers my research he
absolutely does not want a discussion
what does he want well he wants to
advance an idea that immigration is a
pure good and that you know the National
Academy of Sciences has found that it we
get this benefit from it and it has to
do with one rights which don't show up
in in a maxim and and an economics
framework it has to do with something
involving the securitization of rights
so that people don't have their rights
taken as if by eminent domain
he knows all this stuff and he just
chooses to continue down this path and
that Sam has seen this with
reza aslan and with glenn greenwald who
in some ways i always thought of as
pretty positive and then i you know he
gets he gets a bug in his head and you
get these incredibly negative people who
don't want to come into a discussion and
it's important to reserve the dunking on
modality mm-hmm for when people are
really not acting as good actors you
know yeah that's kind of what I did with
I decided to take a lawsuit out against
wilfred laurier so that would do weeks
ago and that was
and you know I've been trying to reserve
my Twitter defense let's say or attack
because it's not always easy to
distinguish between those like I learned
to leave people alone when they make
untoward comments unless they are
journalists of some repute or professors
of some repute in which case I think I
have a moral obligation not to remain
silent right and so it's not so easy to
figure out when you should defend
yourself and when you should shut up
well forever is the wrong time to go and
refer that we don't defend ourselves
because it's as you always have this
problem of special pleading are you
defending yourself because you believe
in the ideas or are you defending
yourself because it's a possible threat
to your own reputation right right right
so that's one of the reasons I came to
your assistance on the enforcement agha
me thing because I didn't want you
having to make that point and if at some
point in the future I get into trouble
and you think that I have married in my
position perhaps you'll return the favor
we can figure out the game theory later
but that's that's what culture actually
does but doesn't that also just feed the
beast in a certain way so every you
defend you know professor goes after you
who has you know no notoriety but just
wants to get in on the game yeah well
now you've defended yourself now next
thing you know box or BuzzFeed is
writing about the professor nobody knows
what and or beat him but let's yeah well
that's a danger for sure look I am also
I am NOT a huge fan of the dunk on
mentality as a opening gambit I am slow
mm-hmm to anger in these situations I
tend to give people three benefits of
the day's work what you should do you
know and so you know for example I had
as recline and his wife over for Shabbat
dinner with dad said you know after the
Sam Harris thing and I wanted to
understand Ezra's position and Ezra had
in fact Vox had done a piece where I
talked about the need to blend hyper
capitalism with hyper socialism in the
future because I think Anthrop I think
about this thing of anthropic capitalism
the capitalism that worked in the 19th
and 20th centuries may have been an
accident for where the parameters were
set in our markets so that it could
function as well as it did and you know
Ezra I don't want to get into all the
personal details of the interaction but
it was fascinating talking to Ezra and
his wife as to how they see the world
and getting behind the scenes look at
what generates Vox so I think it's very
important to try to be charitable in
understanding other people and
understanding their motivations but
there is a point when you've hit
something three four or five times the
person's evidence comp comprehension and
then they go into this mode like you
talked about this with Kathy Newman
where you had one kind of interaction
with her before and then suddenly
assembly three two one go and it's like
so what you're really saying yeah where
did that personality come out of and
that has to do in part with you know the
masks that we all put on I think that
one of the things is I know you as both
personally this mirrors is it how we
talk yeah in a different context but
when you know when when Vox is the weeds
discussed the intellectual dark web I
thought it was incredibly confused very
interestingly after the Barry Weiss
article almost no one from the standard
media called me up to clarify to sort of
learn more because Barry was the owner
of this thing and so it was assumed that
Barry had named it that this was Barry's
meat and so Barry was the go-to person
as if we were all owned by the
particular member of the commentariat
who decided to actually blow this up and
make it large we have to become more
charitable I do think that in part part
of the problem that we've been having
with the sort of madness and the
progressives is that first of all unlike
the Charlottesville right the
progressives are in the establishment
whereas the tiki torch holders right are
like often their mother's garage and
that's a big big difference and so one
of the reasons we're animated is that
you know you remember that line that's
coming from inside the house yeah on the
other hand I do see a lot of points that
these people have that they're just
terribly miss instantiating the problem
of the progressives in my estimation I
you know might have my family has been
progressive since the 20s is it they're
terrible at what they do they're just
not good progressive it's like a really
malignant well I have it formed well let
me give an example yeah
English is odd in the
is inflected for gender only in the
third-person singular
now Turkish for example is not inflected
for gender there's one pronoun o for
he/she/it
so you don't have this problem in
Turkish when you're referring to a
character and story who's not present we
had this problem for in English form
inflected inflection for marital status
which was true for females and not males
mister was mister but miss and missus
gave you more information so there was a
one time backwards incompatible change
that got made with MS and it you know it
still rankles cuz it doesn't sound great
but I think was a good idea and to me to
give women the Equality that they
deserved and shouldn't have to ask for
okay if you wanted to actually do the
pronoun thing for English would you
start with trans or would you start with
intersex now if you started with
intersex everyone is intellectually
sympathetic with intersex there are
people whose gender or sex is ambiguous
right because of the way in which
development sort of takes female and
turns it into male if the sry protein is
present so does everyone who understands
this just to be clear not everyone who
hears about this but everyone who has in
general no matter how conservative
somebody is if I tell them there's a
person born with ambiguous genitalia or
you know that they've got an sry protein
on an X chromosome or they have a
malfunctioning one on a Y so that they
appear to be the opposite phenotype for
their genotype
there's compassion if this person was
born a soul was born without the
expected assignment and there's no
question about development and should we
be steering you should be more male you
should be more masculine more feminine
in order to avoid like the sky-high
suicidal
temptations for people who feel that
they are one thing well evidencing that
they are something else in the physical
okay you would make the change based on
intersex you'd make a one-time backwards
incompatible change to the language with
it approach and pronoun like Turkish has
and then Tran
would have what it wanted without this
craziness of everybody gets to design
their own personal pronoun which is a
disaster like in a computer science
course you would never allow people
you'd give them a choice so that the
coding can go through everybody can't
have their own pronoun right and so
that's how you do it and if you wanted
it to win that's how you you'd push it
through now what they want is something
else they want to say something like
trans women are no less women than women
who were born biologically female well
that's not true right I understand it is
the case that every single culture every
traditional culture of which I'm aware
there is gender ambiguity in south
sulawesi you have a priestly class from
it in India you have the hydras you know
turkeys national treasure Zeki Muren was
more feminine than Liberace I've just
came from Italy where the in the oficial
eree there's an entire room called the
hermaphrodite room dedicated to a
beautiful statue of a ostensibly female
recumbent model with a male genitalia
there is you know the Charlotte not the
Shah of Iran the Ayatollah in Iran came
out with a proclamation that it was okay
to have gender reassignment surgery so
we it's not like traditional cultures
don't know about this it's not like we
haven't made accommodation it's always
been an issues whether it's the Coutu
ease and in Thailand which are among the
best spoken and most educated people
that you meet as a traveler the issue is
that we somehow wanted to make a wedge
issue out of this I am going to force
you to say things that aren't true as an
evidence of my power as opposed to well
that's why exactly why I opposed the
legislation in Canada to begin with
because part and parcel what came along
with that as part and parcel of it and
this was no accident was a legal
insistence that gender differences were
associated socio socio-culturally
constructed it's like well they're not
and I thought well what the hell why are
we enshrining that viewpoint into law I
mean that's not to say that gender
doesn't very gender expression doesn't
vary substantially because of
socio-cultural conditions because you
have to be a fool not to see
that's the case but that's another
situation where the the
multi-dimensional complexity seems to
exceed the processing capacity of the
ideologue ziz that there's more than one
factor at work no no they know what
they're doing like for example should a
skirt be seen as feminine or masculine
well we know from India where the lung
EES is popular for Scotland where
there's a kilt that this is a variable
in other words you shouldn't hard-code
skirts are for girls
mm-hmm right and so the idea is there's
a huge developmental aspect to learning
here are the assignments in your culture
now at some point you want to steer
people into we have a huge interest in
the breeding family is the core of
lineage in a society and we need to care
both about gaze about people of
uncertain gender non-binary people etc
but we can't lose sight of the fact that
we also have to care about the fam the
breeding family in distress yeah we also
have to provide people with an easy
pathway to a reasonably stable identity
well they don't confuse them too this is
the point is that they have an argument
that I think we are learning that gender
undiscovered is far more common than we
ever thought although far less prevalent
than the discussion seems to suggest you
do have a societal interest in steering
people to roles if it's possible but
once somebody is like committed ly
non-binary a switch has to flip on us
and we have to become compassionate and
recognize that we have a soul that we
have to take care of and we do have to
make some allowances if you if you know
anybody who's intersex for example you
know that it's a terrifying state that
they face violence I mean you know why
don't you see dudes kissing I always
claim that it's the implied threat of
violence where if it makes people
uncomfortable you don't see people
holding hands quite so comfortably and
you don't see people being themselves so
if we for example in the IDW stood up
for intersex and say this is the right
way to do what you're doing I think it
would be an absolute service to the
world because that's something we could
push through
I don't think that the conservative you
know Christians in this country are
going to have it die hard they're gonna
feel like well if the Lord made people
in that way we have to accept all the
products of God's creation where do you
fall on that because this is where
people will say well Jordans against
trans people and gay people I mean all
the nonsense yeah well then I hear about
the situation in Canada that was quite
clear is that the the federal government
following the provincial governments
decided that it was okay to impose
requirements for the regulation of
speech and I didn't care what the reason
for that was I thought that it was a
terrible legislative move and partly not
because it wasn't only compelled speech
I read the policy guidelines that were
the framework within which this bill was
to be interpreted there's pages and
pages of them all on the Ontario Human
Rights Commission website which was
linked to the federal website where they
had announced how this bill would be
interpreted and it contained all sorts
of terrible things like the insistence
that gender was was a social
socio-cultural construct and it's in
part a socio-cultural construct and
these things are this you cannot do that
because all of a sudden the legislation
says seem to imply that a discussion
about the biological differences between
men and women might be regarded as hate
speech and I also think we're a fair
ways along that pathway in Canada so I
don't think that my fears about the bill
were unwarranted and I think that what
happened at Wilfrid Laurier University
is an absolutely perfect example of that
so I think that my stance on that piece
of legislation was substantively correct
now the problem is is that or the the
treachery that was involved in the bill
because I see the bill as an attempt by
the radical left who gained linguistic
dominance or increasing linguistic
dominance over the conversation as a
whole using trans people as the
sacrificial victims and by the way I got
no shortage of letters from trans people
saying I'm not so happy being used as a
sacrificial victim for the left to
advance its linguistic hegemony I got a
lot more letters like that from trans
people than I did from trans people
criticizing what I did mm-hmm so and I
also think that this would have all died
away very rapidly if all it was about
was one professors objection to the
rights of trans people that had very
little to do with it let's just take
this in take this bull by the horns
right now am i correct and I you and I
have not discussed this that your point
would be that law is the wrong place to
do it and the culture would be the right
place yes absolutely okay this has to be
boredom up like the MS thing was I
understand that so my point is boys
absolutely the wrong things come from us
I mean in other words this thing has
been so crazily interpreted by the press
this is this is absolute malpractice as
far as I'm concerned by our journal this
is journey genic malpractice well I
should I should speak up for some of the
journalists in Canada because the the
post media group there's 200 newspapers
came out in support of my stance so
there are those who aren't doing but my
point is is that the fact that we're
still having to discuss this is a tax on
all kinds of discussion the more time I
have to spend saying I'm not alright
you know transphobic I don't want to the
fact that I'm in an interracial marriage
because I opposed these you know equity
equity proposals that are in complete
abomination right right remember when
you and I were in Tempe Arizona that the
comedy club and I said something like
you know we shouldn't be celebrating
this I'm at an interracial marriage and
everybody look yeah stop it yeah unless
a few of you our admissions officers to
Ivy League schools in which case I'll
talk I know it's a terrible thing okay
that yeah you happen to fall in love
with a person of color is yeah that's
not a moral or is there a metal you know
in your future you don't want it now
what I'm trying to say is something
slightly different which is I want in on
the positive aspects of the social
transformation I know that my intersex
people are hurting and I know that trans
people are present in every culture
without the social justice stuff and we
should be spearheading what the
incompetent progressive left can't get
done that is that what we're doing
what's one of the things that I want to
be doing like you know gay marriage
turned on a dime over a very short
period of time like smoking right
somehow there's no smoking in bars it's
all
incredible you know if you're old enough
to think about that we should be
spearheading this thing because they
can't get the job done what is our point
not in law yep not in law but do it in
culture you can't have everybody do his
or her own pronouns which is an absolute
disaster but we could settle on you know
and you could do hey hey and they you
know pronouns or something like this I
don't know what the right thing get a
linguists to figure out the the
minimally intrusive one-time backwards
incompatible change to the language it's
gonna be painful I'm not looking forward
to it but we could get it done so one of
the things that I've been doing in my
public lectures is talking about the
appropriate and responsible position of
the left so you know on it seems to me
that if you're pursuing goals that have
value which you have to do because you
have to do things in order to stay alive
you have to pursue goals of value if you
do that in the social social space which
you're compelled to do then you're going
to produce hierarchies because people
different incompetence and you actually
want to produce hierarchies that are
based on competence because they're
efficient tools for getting that
particular job done and so it's a
reasonable position for people on the in
the center and on the right to say stand
behind the hierarchies but by the same
token hierarchies can tilt towards
corruption and tyranny and they tend to
dispossessed people because talents are
distributed unequally right so the left
the position of the left that's the
appropriate position is to speak up for
the dispossessed to keep the hierarchies
flexible enough so that they don't turn
into tyranny and so then you have a
dialogue between the right and the left
that's necessary to maintain the
hierarchy but also to prune it and keep
it healthy and so one of the things that
we could conceivably contribute to is to
improve the health as you're pointing
out conceptually and otherwise of the
dialogue on the left it's like to give
the devil a vision so to speak and and
to say that of course there's a place
for the left the question is when do
they go too far which is what I've been
trying to be a moderate solver and think
about this
this is beyond communism if you think
about one phrase that sums up the theory
of communism what would you what would
you say with the most famous for it
probably from each according to their
ability to each according to their need
now look at the first part of that
phrase from each according to their
ability right so the idea is that there
are different abilities acknowledged in
the very core of communism beyond that
yeah right right oh yes show that well I
think the most pathological the deepest
uni-dimensional pathology that
characterizes the radical left is
actually an attack on competence itself
and so when I was at the Aspen ideas
festival a couple of days ago I made the
case that our hierarchies in the West
are determined at least in part by
competence right now the degree to which
it's pure competence can be disputed but
intelligence and conscientiousness are
the best predictors of long-term life
success even though they don't predict
more than about 25 percent of the
variance but the buzz surrounding what I
said was that Jordan Peterson is
validating the current patriarchy by
making the radical claim that it's
predicated on competence it's like well
why would they twist that argument
because it isn't what I said I said that
their competence is a partial
contributor to our successful
hierarchies and I think the reason is is
that the the very idea of differential
competence is unacceptable to the most
radical well hang on select let's look
at two separate systems because I think
that what people do is they focus on one
rather than the other and I've had to
learn how to do this if we look at chess
which can be made blind where you don't
know who you're playing across the
internet and we look at musical
additions for classical orchestras where
you can put people behind a screen and I
think this became popular in the 80's
90's a particular bassist who is also a
psychologist may have been instrumental
in getting this changed when you
introduced the screen women's
participation and orchestras went up
right so it was a very positive social
program because competency was
apparently being suppressed by
perception by prejudice it was a
structural problem now maybe it didn't
go as far as people want wanted maybe
didn't get to 50/50 I don't know what
the stats are I can look in on
when you do it in chess I don't believe
it has a positive effect when they did
it in the australian civil service for
blind Seavey's it had the opposite
effect women got under selected right so
you're saying even the layers but you're
saying is that this is situationally
situation that say the point is is that
the people who want to talk about chess
where the hundred top hundred players
last I checked it was 99 to one male to
female which is so like even with
structural bigotry man that's hard to
explain
in the other case of the classical
orchestras it was a twenty percent
increased participation of females
that's a giant amount and they're both
true and so the problem is when you push
everything and you shove it into the low
dimensional space you have this idea of
is this structural misrepresentation or
is it something else
well it's both and it's situationally
dependent my wife had to make a point to
me which I was blind to because in
physics almost nothing matters other
than like horsepower and creativity you
don't care whether somebody's red green
blue male/female it's just like almost
nobody's got interesting ideas it's so
hard to make any progress whatsoever you
just want to take the far right tail of
the distribution and you don't want to
be harassed about anything other than
that right no math it's like that math
math methods potentially even work yeah
yeah my wife had to say to me you know
Eric not everything looks like
theoretical physics or differential
geometry in fact if you think about
community policing it can be extremely
important to have diversity because why
do you want one ethnic group policing
another ethnic group or all cops being
male you want diversity in order to have
good relations so that people see
themselves reflected on the force and if
there is bigotry and Prejudice it
manifests itself it's harder to manifest
if people are in fact differs so that
was a bit of a wake-up call the other
thing came from the harvard math
department where it for a period of time
it appeared that they would let in one
woman a year into the ph.d program and
then
she would have a terrible year and she'd
drop out mm-hmm and then one year a
woman deferred her admission and so they
added another woman and this you had two
women in the first year and the two of
them reinforced each other's reality
like you know I think I just said
something and everybody ignored it or I
made a point in than somebody else went
to the chalkboard and wrote it down as
if it was his idea and this group of two
women stayed in the program and that
meant that the next year that there was
one woman led in okay now there's a
group of three and that was a situation
in which there was an organic change in
the apparent ability of women now we
made to be differentiating that we can't
keep reacting to this Lariat analysis
right right we can't we have to be the
ones who are saying look let me steal
man your point you're making a terrible
version of this argument I think I can
even do better and you're welcome right
because the other thing it's doing is
it's deranging our conversation this is
why I had you talk to Ben an asking
point-blank about whether he would use
the pronouns and his point was I will in
general be happy to use somebody's
preferred program except if we're
discussing trans issues which in which
case it is to cede the argument that
Mary is not right he doesn't want to
publicly see the argument and privately
that's an agnostic grounds open about it
and this is what we have to stop
reacting to the mat to the crazy-making
substrate so basically you think that
for the people that are keeping their
foot on the pedal at the highest
possible level we sort of just have to
let that go but do you think it would be
enough so it let's say tomorrow you
started we finished this show today and
you say all right I'm gonna start being
the champion for all the the compassion
that trans people I mean I know you're
compassionate to all people but I'm
gonna be publicly more compassionate to
trans people and intersex people and all
of and address all of the issues that
you just brought up if there's another
set of people that are never gonna throw
you a bone on that that are never gonna
give you a little outreach on that does
it actually do anything or you think it
just allows us to get the refugees
that'll kind of wake up around it I
think that we're
being drained of our empathy let me let
me say I am being drained of my empathy
you know there was a there was a tweet
that the Kentucky Planned Parenthood put
out where it was one of these yeah yeah
remember it was a some some men have
have a uterus and they repeated it like
11 sighs yeah that's a big thing and if
they'd written some trans men have a
uterus or if they'd written something
but we have to be compassionate the
people who identify as you know what it
whatever I would be okay but the idea of
some men have you well there's actually
something called persistent malaria
inducts syndrome where people who are
phenotypically male at birth appear to
have a uterus because of the mysteries
of development them again the fact that
males and females are one protein away
from each other hmm and treating each
other like we're separate tribes as
opposed to you know Fisher like
compliments is absolutely insane and so
I find myself making fun of these people
and I had some tweet about you know
either we're talking about persistent
Eulerian duck syndrome or you're just
eating crayons helping a pooping a
rainbow and you know I thought about
this I thought I'm so unsympathetic with
you're trying to smuggle ideology into
my world yes you can compassion to the
laboratory yeah yeah and you know this
is it's reprehensible
bugling ideology under the guise but you
know just gets back to this issue that
we have been having this expert
conversation in the literature where all
sorts of things that cause people to
clutch pearls and they're feigning
couches are absolutely parts of the you
know parts of the literature in biology
and psychology and anthropology all of
these places and now everything is
discussed everywhere so when you hear
you know that there are group
differences it's shocking if you haven't
been part of the professional civil
conversation and I think that that's a
big problem is is that this is this
esoteric versus exoteric speak which is
the sort of intellectual elite in the
universities have this private way of
talking amongst themselves in journals
and then this public way of talking and
this is absolutely essential in some
areas but it's being abused in others so
for example the trade theorists know
that what they talk about it not the
importance of free trade based on
Ricardian equivalence and comparative
advantage is a [ __ ] argument it's a
very crude thing that's very hard to
argue with mathematically but behind the
scenes they're having a completely
different conversation and they have the
idea of were entitled to do this an
answer in from my perspective is you
just replaced one concept which was
Kaldor Hicks improvement with with
Pareto improvement Pareto improvement
makes everybody better off Kaldur Hicks
leave some people worse off and some
people better off and you'd have to tax
the better off to compensate for the
worse that well we're having a
countrywide freak out because the
economists have developed two separate
conversations one for the public where
they push out things that are not
necessarily good for the median
individual very bad for a particular
communities life and a separate
conversation that they're having amongst
themselves and they're serving these
interests well we have to do something
about this we can no longer this goes
back to your gutenberg point in the
technology issue we cannot have this
level of division between the private
and public conversation I know more
about what's wrong with the immigration
in the high-tech sector than the
National Academy feels National Academy
of Sciences wants to discuss they are at
the center effectively of a conspiracy
in the 1980s and early 90s to change the
laws of the United States in order to
make it impossible for young scientists
to bargain with PhDs in hand with their
employers to get the six-figure salaries
that the market was going to give them
now we can we can play a game where the
National Academy is having a private
conversation with me where they've had
me four or five times over there and
they're not going to have any reflection
of this in the public but I now have you
know a hundred thousand Twitter
followers and I know why people are
angry about immigration it has nothing
to do with immigrants it has to do with
transfers it has to do with the fact
that our ruling classes have been
figuring out how to
transfer money from one group of
Americans to another group of Americans
and if they could use puppies they use
puppies because you can't object to
puppies okay well the problem is is is
that you now have a group of people who
are able to have these conversations
that say let me show you the playbook
let me show you what's really going on
on in these technical discussions there
if there are differences between groups
that are measurable IQ I don't think any
of us really want to be talking about
race and IQ particularly but when you
try to say there is absolutely no
evidence to show well that's not going
to be true and the scientists are going
to have to say look I don't I don't
right reality I report on what the
literature says let me tell you what the
literature says and the literature says
some things that we don't want it to say
but that's that there's nothing new
about that lots of science is very
upsetting
evolutionary theory is upsetting
psychology is upsetting and this
upsetting literature we haven't figured
out what we are going to do culturally
as it becomes available to everybody and
we have people who are sort of gleefully
talking about things like racing like
you and I want to tell them cut it out
that's you know we don't really know
everything but we're getting more and
more knowledge and I'm worried about
where it can go and we have other groups
of people who say you know there's
absolutely nothing to this race an IQ
thing I'm just thinking oh this is like
asbestos you're you're now making an
attempt to stir up the asbestos to try
to get rid of it and you're gonna loosen
all these fibers rather than doing this
professionally and scientifically the
right way so I do think that there's an
issue about the esoteric the exoteric
and what it is that we are going to do
as experts to handle the knowledge that
we've been sort of exposed to and that
the public hasn't and it's coming out in
the worst ways and this is part of
what's fueling the whole make America
great again the situation which is the
public knows something is off with their
expert communities the expert
communities are not being honest about
literature so I would say that right
there is the magic of what I've been
it's been such a pleasure of being part
of with you for these last two months or
so that you are giving people a little
bit of Oh all of these people know
something's not right the information
we're getting
is not right the language we're speaking
is not right the way we're talking about
government is not right everything that
Eric just said right there and you're
giving them a little room every day to
figure it out for themselves well
there's two things that are happening
one is because of the long form it's
actually possible to have more in-depth
discussions about these things and the
other is that because my lectures let's
say and the discussions that I've been
having focus on the development of ideas
rather than on the ideas themselves that
then gives people a bit of breathing
space one of the questions that I'm
really curious about is and I'd like to
know what you think about this is what
do you think it is that's fundamentally
driving the radicalness of the left like
what because it does seem so
counterproductive even to the left's own
stated positions you know because when I
was in Aspen for example mm-hmm I talked
about the literature on biological
differences between men and women in in
psychology right it's like mostly men
and women are similar even in the
dimensions where they differ most
there's way more overlap than there is
difference right so aggression is a good
example of that so if you take a random
man and a random woman out of the
population and you had to bet on who was
the more aggressive if you bet on the
man you'd be right 60 percent of the
time but that's not that much but then
all the actions at the tails right so
you don't care about however aggressive
the average person is you care about how
aggressive the really aggressive people
are and they're all male and so you end
up putting them in prison which accounts
for the massive differential between men
and women and prison rates and so you
can have small differences at the mean
and radical differences at the extremes
so and that's the fact that people don't
understand that is he is partly willful
blindness on the part of the
ideologically committed but also partly
because it's somewhat complex
statistically but then I think about the
like the audience that I was addressing
at Aspen
they weren't happy about me talking
about biological differences in
personality between men and women and I
thought well what the hell do you want
exactly from your leftist perspective is
like why is it so necessary for you to
make the presumption that there cannot
be
any differences whatsoever between men
and women it's like well first of all
there are so that's a big problem for
your theory but why all of a sudden has
this become an axiomatic position of the
left that these differences can't exist
when what you want to do in principle is
free up people to make choices I think
that our to make choices in a market
that would allow for those choices in
keeping with their intrinsic nature like
why did that I don't understand why
that's shifted and what's interesting is
you're talking about the intellectual
liberal elite that's the type of people
you were talking in front of right it's
right you're it's nothing you were just
talking in front of just a group of
lefties or a group of righties or
something about you know the Primo is
the commentariat yeah all right look so
what do you do with that well let me
come straight at it we on the Left had
an idea that if we could get rid of
cultural bias in IQ testing if we could
get rid of misogyny that was structural
in the workplace that we would get a
particular kind of outcome and we did
make things better in many ways but it
didn't go as far as we were expecting
hmm and so this is what people are
wrestling with and it you know I
hesitate to call it this but I think
it's the most powerful way of saying it
it's the Great Depression shortage of
2018 mm-hmm and the problem is is that
there still is structural oppression I
mean yes look at Robert Moses design of
New York City's highways bridges and
byways
famously trying to keep buses from going
to Jones Beach I guess is it Jones yeah
- Jones Beach he literally I mean I grew
up in Long Island the bus the the bridge
is going over the LA at that area are
lower because they didn't want Mills out
into Harlem so that it doesn't affect
real estate prices somewhere else on the
east side so you know there really is
structural oppression the way there was
when there were literacy tests for
voting which were constructed so that no
black person could could pass because it
was impossible okay but there's less of
it now and there's not enough of it to
explain some of the differences and the
the great fear is is that the Left
program to try to produce
better representation better
opportunities for women for minorities
whatever is going to stall out if we
start to think of these things as
differences okay so why is it a problem
okay fair enough why is it a problem if
it stalls out though is it because
there's all sorts of radical activists
who then don't have anything to do or is
there that's part of it that's what you
seen with the Southern Poverty Law
Center oh yes which is that you have an
institution that fundamentally
accomplished much of its mission but
then it still had a large kitty and idle
idle hands
it sounds like humanities departments to
me right okay and we can get to that
yeah but I also want to steel man the
other position so that you have
something to fight against or directly
wrestle with if I think about I do
something different with women in the
workplace with respect to trying to
figure out what is unfair to them
because there are things that are very
unfair to them and one of the things I
do is to say tell me about the great
ideas of females and the great
contributions that are sitting there on
the table in part because they had a
female Discoverer right so you could
look at you know Veera Reubens work in
which never you know never got a Nobel
Prize everybody knows about it in in
astrophysics but I went through one of
these things with my wife where we did
this thing with gage theory and
economics in the Harvard Economics
Department and I think it was one of the
most sensational breakthroughs in
mathematical and bedrock economic theory
in the last 25 years and I'll just be
very clear every time people want to
figure out how to tax Americans more and
cut their benefits without paying the
price of touching the so called third
rails of politics they realize that the
CPI indexes both tax receipts and
entitlements so payments like Social
Security and Medicare and if you can
show that the CPI is overstated then the
idea is that you get to take in more tax
revenue and you get to pay old people
and sick people less and so it's a very
popular game in Washington to
gerrymander the measure gerrymander the
measurement now the two ways that you do
that one is is that you go from a fixed
basket where you have let's say
basketballs and glasses
you figure out what the price of that
basket is over time to something which
is what is the utility so the idea is
maybe I want slightly more glasses or
basketball you can do it with coffee and
tea I'm willing to trade off some amount
of coffee for some amount of tea to get
my caffeine fix if there's a problem or
a bumper crop in Brazil okay the other
thing you do is is that you keep
updating these baskets and that's called
chaining mm-hmm well you can't do both
of those things together because there's
a a presumed impossibility result that
you can't have a true cost of a chain
cost-of-living index except that my wife
and I solved that problem in the
mid-1990s at the same time that the
Boston Commission was trying to back out
a an exact 1.1 percent overstatement
because that would save a trillion
dollars so in other words you have to
understand they were given the task go
find a 1.1% overstatement and justify it
so that we can cut benefits and raise
taxes and my wife got in the middle of
that bank robbery as it was being
attempted and so she got flagged now I
wanted to fight these sons of [ __ ]
absolutely in particular there's a
professor named Dale Jorgenson who
spearheaded the attempt to really crush
her and when she was on the she was
getting her dissertation this is great
work and the cost of it Jordan is is
that there's great work done by women
that is sitting there because
fundamentally the women don't want to
fight the way you and I would fight for
our work because it's not necessarily
fun it's unpleasant and you know with me
I have a very aggressive response to
this it's like how dare you talk about
my work do you know how much better my
work is than your work and let's do this
now well that's it that's a complicated
thing too because you know for for a
piece of brilliant work to rise up to
the point where it's universally
acclaimed it takes a lot more than
merely the brilliant work that's like
it's like it's like putting a product
out into the marketplace like a consumer
product you might have a brilliant
product but the fact that you have a
brilliant product is about 5% of what
you need to have a successful product
because the rest of it is sales and
marketing and then
if so you might say there's many ideas
that we have taken stock of that we
should have taken stock of those that we
have taken stock of over this weird
combination of brilliant idea plus
brilliant and forceful marketing plus
luck all right and so so if if it's the
case for example that because women are
less assertive they're less likely to
fight those ideas forward although
equally likely to generate as many
brilliant ideas then that's going to
cause a decrement in their movement
forward well we need to contend with
well that's what I'm trying to say which
is that fundamentally the reason I asked
for don't tell me about the women being
suppressed tell me about the ideas of
women so I can I can use my aggress as
long as we have a male dominated system
you have men who want to fight for great
ideas well but then the question is do
we have a male dominated system or do we
have a dominance dominated right so this
is Frank let me let me let me tease this
apart I have been in I think five almost
all male fields I've touched mathematics
theoretical physics economics finance
and tech and they're not all male but
they're dark male dominated fields one
of those fields I found had a cancerous
attitude towards women that was just
visible so I got a chance to see in
finance all of the bad behavior that
people talked about about the
objectification about you know locker
room talk which was just absolutely
natural not in every context but it was
often enough in the other fields in
general like in math I I don't think I
ever heard people making nasty comments
about women so in the same weird way
it's not like I'm deaf to it because I
can hear it in one case I didn't hear it
very often in the other case in physics
I didn't hear many nasty comments about
women but it was incredible theory for a
period of time was incredibly aggressive
like labor economics was super
aggressive symplectic geometry inside of
math was super female friendly so there
is definitely this difference in texture
between the these different places in
male-dominated fields and having seen
relatively benign male-dominated
that hyper toxic male-dominated field I
can tell you that I don't love going
into a particle Theory seminar where
everybody's peacocking because it's it's
relatively uninteresting relative to the
work well you would say to some degree
that would indicate that that the system
has become somewhat corrupt in the ways
that systems can be corrupt and that
what's pushing you forward in those
fields is less about competence and more
about dominant I don't know well I don't
know either but you could you could you
could you could generate that as a
hypothesis but I'll tell you one of the
things our psychometric work has
revealed this is quite interesting is
when we've looked at differences in men
and women with regards to outcome and
then controlled for personality right
the personality difference is almost
always obliterate the gender differences
which means it's actually not a gender
difference it's a personality difficulty
but let's flip that because this is it
isn't always things I know I understand
that so I think that that's very
important but now you're gonna get cuz I
should say then I DS have agreeable man
yes in these fields might be as likely
by be totally yeah I totally agree with
you now here's here's the next part of
it many let's say let's let's not do it
as male/female let many agreeable people
have the idea that the problem is is
that the fields are so tilted towards
disagree ability now I don't happen to
believe this mhm that we are losing good
ideas because agreeable people can't
make progress and in those circumstances
the claim isn't let's just have an open
competition and see what rises to the
top it's let's change the structure of
things now this okay so there's a
problem with that so let me point it was
another psychometric problem with that
okay if you look at what predicts
success in workplaces generally what
predicts is IQ and conscientiousness
agreeable this is a very trivial
predictor now one of the things you do
see is that agreeable people tend to get
paid less for the same work but we don't
know why that is exactly we don't know
if they don't bargain as well I think
that's the simplest explanation is that
they're they're it's easier to take
advantage of agreeable people it's
almost like the definition of agreeable
it's the downside of being agreeable but
agreeable this is not a very good
predictor of workplace success
there's
actually a corrupt literature that's
associated with this because there's a
whole literature on emotional
intelligence emotional intelligence puts
you ahead in the workplace it's like no
it doesn't emotional intelligence is
almost in indiscriminate rate
agreeableness and trade agreeableness
actually puts you behind in the
especially in the managerial domain now
you might say well that means the
managerial domain is prejudiced against
agreeable people but then there's some
evidence that disagreeable people make
better managers and the reason for that
is that they can't be pushed around
because you know if you're a manager you
might say well what you have to do is
you have to deal with the concerns of
your employees and that would be the
agreeable interpretation but sometimes
if you're a manager you have to take the
slackers and give them hell yeah and
that's a that's something that only a
disagreeable person can do this is the
throat but there isn't much evidence on
the psychometric front that
agreeableness that that agreeableness is
a is a major contributor to workplace
success in general so it isn't obvious
to me from the psychometric work that
the idea that hierarchies in general are
contaminated by a preference for
disagreeable people I don't see any
evidence for that well look part of the
problem with this whole discussion is is
that you have there are roles in which
agree ability works there's you can team
where there's you need a certain balance
of these things yes it probably works
for customer service for example to be
agreeable right and be forgetful people
carrot people so all of these things I
mean the world didn't come up with big
five traits and distribute us across
them if they if they don't have
advantages like right you are you know
it wouldn't know I father is and he can
he can he can see animals in the bush
better than me as I was gonna make the
point is that from my perspective your
contrast Blanc right right and the idea
is that when I'm talking about this that
strikes color normal people as very
strange with well it's a strange way to
look at the world but the fact is is
that these traits are retained because
they have different uses yes that's
right that is the fact if you focus on
the right tail of the distribution the
extreme right tail if you hang out with
billionaires very often in order to get
to billionaire status you have to be
able to oppose large numbers of people
and say they're all wrong and I'm right
mm-hmm and then you also have to be
right and even worse right right and you
have to be disagree obsolete but you
know if I look at some of the things
that that my friend Peter teal can do
that I find very few people can it's
like can you hold a position even if you
know two years from now you're gonna be
proven right with two years of scorn
yeah the average person is going to
crumble yeah well that would also be
partly trait neuroticism people have to
be able to tolerate that level of stress
and that's very very difficult this is
what I'm trying to get it which is that
people are looking at various reward
structures and they're saying well that
doesn't match my particular set of
traits and I feel that my traits are
valuable in those traits probably our
value yeah but we are not all destined
to become Beyonce or Peter Thiel but
more joy but what seems to be happening
that that's exactly right that's exactly
right but what seems to be happening I
think like if you look at the
Scandinavian countries the the more
egalitarian Scandinavian countries
that's where you're getting the most
radical assortment of occupational
status by gender and so I would say for
example that if you tilt towards
agreeableness which is actually a pretty
good predictor of interest in people
rather than interest in things the
biggest difference between men and women
seems to be an interest right men are
reliably more interested in things and
women more reliably interested in people
the difference is one standard deviation
so it's a big difference right and what
seems to be happening in the
Scandinavian countries is people are
sorting themselves by their temperament
which is what they should do because
your your temperament as you just
pointed out predisposes you to success
in some realm and not in others right
you don't get both and failure and yes
and failure so because women are on
average more agreeable and perhaps
higher and negative emotion it isn't
obvious how that fits into the equation
they're more sensitive to the distress
of others and more likely to be
compassionate in their care so what
happens you open up the landscape of
competitiveness to women they
immediately dominate the healthcare
fields and that's exactly what's
happened now part of the problem with
that is that health care as an
occupation doesn't scale well like
engineering does for example and so it's
very difficult to generate large fortune
in healthcare and that's one of the
things that skews the gender
distribution of wealth but it looks like
if we left people be to the degree that
we can they would sort themselves into
occupations by temperament and that
might be the variations it's
questionable like when when we had our
first child we had a wrote a practice
where there was a rotation of the ob/gyn
would deliver we had this one woman we
were totally on the same page with we
loved her everything about it was
fantastic we were we were simpatico
and my wife's labor went on and on and
on and on we supposedly we were getting
closer and closer
finally sheep this woman couldn't take
it anymore she said I got to go to sleep
mm-hmm and the guy that we dreaded the
six-foot-four guy with the bowtie who
came from a totally different era we
called him the Undertaker he comes in
and he says she's completely blown where
we are in the process you're barely
dilated at all we need to deliver this
child immediately via cesarean mm-hmm
huh right well this son of a [ __ ] saved
the situation for my for my my wife and
my daughter
yep and yep the ideas I didn't like him
one absolutely meant that happens and
that goes a woman who diagnosed our
daughter with with arthritis same thing
I was really mad at her really mad at
her she was very disagreeable and she
was right
and let's be very clear passion and
right are not the same same thing the
woman who the reason that we didn't have
big flipper babies for thalidomide
commonly in the United States was one
woman who I think went to University of
Chicago at like 16 and she stood up and
said I don't like the data on this drug
and I don't I don't think you drug
companies have done enough to prove to
me that this is safe to prescribe to
pregnant woman and she just put up her
hand and stopped it
now I don't know what you I'm gonna use
son of a [ __ ] that son of a [ __ ] saved
how many I mean she's a national hero
right right and we should be celebrating
and that the issue is is that it's not
down to health care agreeable or
disagreeable the problem is is that we
now have so much information about
ourselves and about the occupations and
the reward structures and there is a lot
of structural unfairness and there is a
lot of unfairness about here's your
endowment and you you
we're given different gifts and then
there's a certain amount of luck mm-hmm
that we are all struggling with the idea
that we have so much information and not
enough oppression to explain this and
we're not necessarily happy with the
outcome we don't know I really want to
have an honest conversation about well
so then okay so there's another element
to that too which is okay the the
question might be to what degree are we
required to tolerate a certain amount of
interactable suffering because that's
the argument you're basically making
you're saying look we can we can
equalize and we can provide opportunity
and we've done we've hit the point of
diminishing returns now not everywhere
obviously and and not in every sector
but you could make the case that we've
hit the point of diminishing returns and
still there's a tremendous amount of
inequality and suffering it's like and
we don't find that acceptable it's yes
yeah but the problem is the more you
push to remove that last bit of inner
article suffering the more likely you
are to produce a worse kickback in
another place that's not an easy thing
to contain and the fact is that we're
going to be discussing this whether or
not NBC CBS or ABC likes it and they
can't do anything about shutting this
conversation down until YouTube or
Twitter you know really decides to get
heavy-handed and give us the boot and so
fundamentally we don't sound like what
we're supposed to send is the sound like
an all trite conversation does it sound
hyper conservative no it's a very
difficult picture and the key problem is
is that the only place that's being
explored is in these super luxurious
long-form interviews I have no idea how
people tune in like when we went to
Tempe people were tracking these
conversations at a level that we're not
tracking the relational hunger to care
they actually carefully know they know
that the cognitive lego they've been
handed is not capable of getting look
surgically look what's happening at
Harvard this is such an interesting
example about about about the entire
landscape it's like the upshot it looks
like the upshot of the of the policies
designed to produce something
approximating equity or at least
equality of opportunity the
gerrymandering of the admissions process
has halved the number of Asians at
Harvard and then Harvard's of course
denying that strenuously they say well
are
selection method is too esoteric to be
captured properly by the statistics it's
like oh that's really how you're gonna
do this nowhere mm-hmm the Harvard math
department I think had one female
mathematician I think it doesn't have a
senior female mathematician then I could
be wrong yeah and I'm sure that the
university is trying to put pressure hey
what's wrong with you guys get with the
program the National Science Foundation
is trying to do that across the entire
STEM disciplines now and they're really
going to muck up math by by playing
around with this because the data show
it's quite interesting the data show
that if you look at junior high there's
approximately there's some dispute about
this there still might be evidence that
there's a small percentage of small
advantage to men at the highest levels
of mathematical ability but I'll leave
that aside for now the more general data
show that there's plenty of gifted women
and there's plenty of gifted girls
there's plenty of gifted boys but the
gifted boys are gifted in math and not
verbally whereas the gifted girls in
math are gifted verbally too and so one
of the consequences is that because math
is a very specialized service the
Trinity costs are higher yeah it's
exactly yeah the girls decide not to
pursue whatever the thing is is that
math perfectly well tolerates
the females that it understands their
work and can't live without I mean if I
think about Emma murder or Karen
uhlenbeck or deucey Macduff there's a
huge number of women who are very well
integrated you know in physics people
like Lisa Randall I I don't even think
about there being women mathematicians
or women physicists just like that
result this paper right right and the ID
thank God for that right but the point
that I'm trying to get at here is is
that there are still structural barriers
and there's probably something that
isn't a structural barrier like for
example you know the incentive
structures and if the pay keeps going
down my guess is that you'll get more
females in which is a totally perverse
effect that's been studied that you
start going into the female and minority
sectors when men feel that they have
higher opportunity cost based on their
level of aggression that they can go to
management consulting or Walsall right
right major complication question is we
need to be able to have the
real conversation somewhere and it needs
to not we also need to have a
conversation about why it might be
advantageous to be paid less one of the
reasons it's it's advantageous to be
paid less is the demands are less on you
so if you have other things that you
want to do with your life then taking a
job that pays less this happens in law
all the time all the time I worked as a
consultant for legal companies for a lot
for law firms for ten years with lots of
high-end women and I saw the same thing
happen all the time it and the law the
law firms know this right to the core
and all the women in the law firms know
it too almost all the women bail out of
the high-end positions in law in their
early 30s well why well it's partly
because if they're making say they're
making 350 to 500 thousand dollars a
year they're charging $1,000 an hour
well the workload is absolutely insane
you better be billing 2300 hours a year
right if you're going to stay in that
position and you're on call all the time
and you're basically working 16-hour
days so maybe maybe what you want to do
instead is find a nine-to-five job that
pays half as much but you get to have a
life more psychotic inside the
universities and here's what here's what
nobody really wants to discuss the great
danger according to many of my
colleagues in well-placed well-placed in
in high-level science departments is
they say the following we don't know
which females are going to discover the
pleasures of family hmm
after we've invested them and so the
idea is is that sometime in their
mid-30s some number of women they think
discover oh my god I've never been so
fulfilled as when I've had my child and
some women say I can't wait to get back
to the lab right and these are two
different reactions so by pushing the
point of commitment farther and farther
towards the middle age what you're doing
is is that you're actually screening out
the fact that you don't know which
people you're going to invest in and are
going to decide that they have something
more interesting to do in their life in
terms of kin work or that compel them
because also has to do with aging
parents right now right in fact is is
that women are more conscientious with
respect to child rearing and with aging
parents Janelle
eclis than men and so part of the gambia
function of being agreeable probably a
function of fitness wear yes yeah you
know the idea is that uncertain mature
uncertain paternity and certain
maternity means that in a highly K
selected species females are going to be
ever more focused on on on on kin in
this way maybe that's the reason that
the difference is in agreeable this
evolved I'm not I've never thought about
that because wow that could be I never
thought about that it's likely
explanation right mmm-hmm but the issue
that fundamentally we would defer tenure
as a means of screening out females who
are going to invest in fritto now it is
very interesting if you look at feminist
scientists in the 50s you have women who
like had four kids and they spent a life
in science and very often you you look
you poke and prod at these things well
there was an army of servants because
there was wealth in the family you know
very often right right and so what what
my claim is if you really want to do
something profound for women and
technical subjects you should pay them
more and you should get them help in the
house didn't work in law well this is
the issue because to some extent it's a
question of fulfillment most of them
most of the women that I work with they
all have nannies they outsource to all
their domestic duties like that was
covered man and that was part of what
Laura tell you but it still did you know
a more successful group of people than I
do because very early I had the money
for well if two people can't get jobs
together and contiguous states yeah you
know it's like oh I've got a job in
Oklahoma and he's got a job in Alabama
and we try to see each other two
weekends a month you know things have
gone wildly off the rails but the key
point is that employers are playing
games trying to figure out this change
in the life cycle where some women are
very very happy doing kick-ass work
throughout their life maybe they can
figure out how to do it all some of them
can some of them can it's pretty hard to
do is pretty hard to do it all it helps
if you have money it does it does help
but we are not owning up to what what
are these games and what are these
differences and where should we be where
should we be subsidy we're also not
owning
to the fact that the gender difference
in pay isn't a gender difference it's a
mother difference because women take the
big hit and their salaries when they
decide to have kids so it is not yes
that no it's not just that but that no
one and nothing is hardly anything has
ever just one thing right but the whole
thing about equal pay for equal work and
seventy-five cents on the dollar right
is that when you poke and prod at that
there is an unfairness and there is a
misrepresentation and the point is we're
not comfortable having the open
conversation about do we want to
subsidize people based on this
difference now my wife has a really
interesting point she said look I
believe in the fish Aryan equivalence
between male and female as strategies
where males tend to be the high-risk
high-return
yea moderate risk modern there was a
time when what wars were common and men
got called up and women didn't have his
high-end prospects and everybody's
working the fields or you know washing
clothes at home and then our point it's
really interesting is knowledge work
became wildly more fulfilling very
quickly in the number of wars and this
is my addendum to it has gone down and
so suddenly it's much better to be male
in her way of thinking than it is female
in a way that was never true before and
so that there is a novelty effect which
is that knowledge work is outpacing the
fulfillment of child rearing at some
level because the the problems that you
can solve if you're well placed to do so
have increased in number and they're
very very fulfilling and and they're
also disproportionately lucrative at
least in some situations are
disproportionately lucrative and so I do
think that one of the things we have to
do you know look at the Vietnam War
Memorial and that I there like eight
female names on it and it's just you
know George Tom Chad you know right
right right so there is this forgetting
of the fact that maleness has this huge
downside which is the high risk part of
the high return stage and you know your
point about interest in things over
people at my local pin ball well there's
always a San Francisco would you know I
take my son there there's
there's a woman's room and they're
clearly pinball machines that are
intended to get a female audience but
it's like 20 to 1
males to females because it's it's this
kind of robotic activity where you're
just putting money into a machine and
you're watching a ball and some flashing
lights I find it quite entertaining but
I look at myself and I think you're
saying chicks me and I'm out of my mind
well you know it's interesting too is
that that high-risk high-return strategy
is also not that common among men it's
just that the people who do the
high-risk high-return strategy are
disproportionately men and so one of the
things that I've been trying to struggle
with is that like there's a small number
of people who are hyper productive in
any discipline and that's the prices law
phenomenon so you see for example in
scientific publishing the median number
of publications for men and women is
very similar a median number but the
people who pop who hyper publish are
almost all men telemon's of science
active or that's right the Jay s box of
science right and and then the painful
part of that is is that it's the people
it looks like it's the people who are
hyper productive that drive the science
forward so the median types are actually
somewhat irrelevant it's only the hyper
productive people that can't you buddy
and their disproportionate but even you
know I've heard you on this yeah I want
to take issue yeah it's Kurt girdle
hyper productive or was he and I would
say yes he was did he publish very much
almost nothing well quantity isn't the
best good one
I don't think so coordinated at point
three with citation count independent of
number other publication counters I know
I know we've got we've got a really
dangerous problem in that the metrics
that we've developed we've put way too
much on and that well that's that's the
you could say that that's a universal
problem be careful what you measure
right and I mean it's hard to measure
scientific impact with any differences
widening is why I'm so unpopular in this
area which is I just believe in giving
slush funds to highly disagreeable
people of high achievement and saying go
figure out who you want to fund because
a lot of this stuff can't be just by any
metric and by the way that's why I'm big
on the selection end of things should
you select qualified people and leave
them the hell alone well I mean I
actually working together on
my take on this is that the best way to
get radical progress to stop worrying
about the median individual worry about
the tiny number of people who break new
ground for everybody and then you find
that's a hell of a thing for a leftist
to say but I mean this goes that tooned
well I think that goes back to the
problem I laid out at the beginning is
that if you're gonna pursue things of
value in a social environment you're
gonna produce a hierarchy and there's
gonna be hyper productivity at the
pinnacle of the hierarchy it's a big
problem but if you want to produce
things that's the problem you have to
contend with and so it is the case that
in in most fields that are attempting to
advance rapidly that it's a very tiny
proportion of people who are doing the
advancing and how could it be otherwise
well because everybody you find the
advance so I you know I have this trick
I guess is a good measure well here's
another one you ask the leaders in the
field effectively who they would block
but they will not publicly short so in
other words yeah
I chose on some crazy tangent he's
wasting the department's resources or
you know Jane fundamentally doesn't play
well on this team and I think we need to
send her a strong message okay well why
don't we say something publicly but no
no I don't want to say that why is it
you don't want to say something well
because you're frightened that that
person has you on the losing end of
history so you're trying to block that
person in private but you won't short
them in public so you use the people who
fundamentally are the regular
establishment to tell you who the most
dangerous people are and you get those
people money and you try to decrease
transparency and accountability because
giving people freedom the old part of
this bargain was it's not the best paid
career in the world but you do end up
with freedoms abilities to know is the
more thing and that's gone and that's
gone the ethics committees have killed
that well my point is as the Yurok
receipts have killed it's gone so behind
man but it is our job to rally for
unaccountability at a very high level
lack of transparency you can laugh but
let's let's go through this right the
fact is when you have a
and you can make decisions that you
don't have to justify based on an
h-index or a citation count or any of
these poison metrics you get people who
are able to make use of what we still
have over places like China that's what
we have over a place like China's were a
little bit richer not much maybe so we
carry here but we're freer and that's
middle finger
that's the blessed middle finger well
that's disagreeableness there again well
I know and I mean you were the one who
knows this is also why tenure is
necessary because you could say well 95
I don't believe this but you could say
95% of people waste tenure they take
advantage of it and I would say that's
fine as long as the 5% large taking
advantage of it have their freedom yeah
they're gonna hyper produce and justify
all the rest of yeah I think nobody has
real tenure because real tenure and
academic freedom was first of all
sacrificed by the Association of
American Universities AAU in 1953 at the
height of the Cold War in the face of
the Rosenbergs so first of all let's be
very very honest the trade group that
represents the nation's top institutions
of higher learning the research
universities [ __ ] up and they killed
something and I don't swear very often
this is very important they sacrificed
academic freedom freedom on an altar
when they were facing something like
worth we're facing with left car theism
all right when they were facing real
McCarthyism they buckled and the
Einsteins of the world stood up there's
a beautiful testimony of a guy who was
facing Senator McCarthy he says well I
was just talking to my friend Albert
Einstein you can see and the transcript
he's like excuse me your friend Albert
Einstein mm-hmm
yeah Einstein said look you have to be
prepared to lose your salary lose your
livelihood if you're going to be a true
intellectual now the fact of the matter
is disagree ability needs to make a
massive roaring comeback right and one
of the things I think is just
fascinating is how many top departments
have invited Brett Weinstein to give a
talk on evolutionary theory after
watching him tossed out by the radical
department suspect the answer to that
zero it's almost zero I don't know that
it may be zero
so this is so with Lindsay Shepard her
claim for with Wilfred Laurier is that
the controversy errs controversy has
made her permanently unemployable and
when I read that I thought that's that's
correct because no hiring committee will
take a risk on it daisuke sure who did
green fluorescent protein he was
supposed to get a Nobel Prize for it he
was acknowledged by the three guys who
did as the fourth guy they flew him to
Sweden and what is he doing you know
immediately afterwards he was driving a
shuttle bus in Huntsville Alabama one
year later after the New York Times
covered dug pressure story was still
driving a shuttle bus in Huntsville
Alabama we're talking about Margo
O'Toole at MIT who stood up against
david baltimore enema to recently manish
Akari you know destroyed now my question
is hey where are the universities is it
the University of Chicago is it down to
the University of Chicago where are the
places Chicago if you're out there you
know we need you we need fundamentally
strong departments and weak
administrations this is absolutely
critical is that anything on that's on
okay we need unaccountability we need
strong professors we need strong
departments we need weak
administration's we need to get people
tenure radically earlier like in their
20s late 20s early 30s we need when
people have the ability to make great
new ideas this is not appreciated and
the fact that fundamentally nobody can
hear Brett Weinstein who has great
interesting theories if you want to
shoot him down by all means but you
won't invite him to give a seminar on
his on his work at a time like this this
is absolute madness and I'm so you know
just what a privilege to be able to deal
with our tiny group of people who can
actually open their throat let me find a
much larger audience than he would have
got any other way well that's gonna say
maybe harkening this all the way back
and then let's do one more thing and
then we're gonna bring in Shapiro but
maybe that brings us back to where we
started about this the speeding of
Technology the amount of people that can
listen and watch and all of that and
that what Brett may find I just brought
Brett up in front of a sold-out comedy
club in Bellevue and he got us when I
just mentioned his name he got a
standing ovation how much those people
edit journals of evolutionary theory so
we have to get it to them I get it it's
a different
that they are watching this right now he
said there's something to be said even
so the obligation front is rough but
there's something to be said for being
able to bring your scientific expertise
to a mass audience who are actually
interested in the content of your
discourse so I'm not saying it's it's
it's it's the revolution in the journals
that might be necessary but it's not
nothing it's and it it looks like
there's the possibility of bringing
these things directly to a mass audience
that's a pretty much I appreciate that
but the thing that nobody gets about
what we're doing because I spend my time
attacking most of the things I'm trying
to save I want to save the New York
Times from itself I want to save the
University how old are you 52 no I you
don't have enough time left to do spoken
like a baby boomer my friend he might
know occur as well you know what we need
to do is either cure it or kill it these
things need or we can let it kill itself
which it seems to be mapped on yeah I
don't have time for that and it's not a
pretty death no and the fact of the
matter is is that it's crowding out
what's next and so fundamentally if it
can be saved if they can be saved they
need to be saved and if they can't be
saved if they fundamentally want to keep
their finger on the scales and push
everything in this direction and the
cowardice is is palpable everywhere it's
important that they stop crowding out
what's next and I think that that's the
major decision and you know quite the
Maurya the marketplace might make that
decision for them we'll see we'll see
maybe it'll be fast maybe it'd be fast
enough so let's let's do one other thing
before Shapiro is going to join us we're
gonna take a little break and have lunch
and then Shapiro is gonna jump in here
so I thought this would be a good segue
to to him because we haven't done that
much politicals yep right here is this
is this a political movement is this the
beginnings of a political movement no I
don't think so I think what it is is the
is the is that conduct it's the
conducting of proper political discourse
and maybe you could say well it would be
a political movement to foster the
conducting of proper political
discourse that's possible but it's a
strange political movement cuz it's a
political movement that's concentrating
on process rather than then then then
then content yeah I think that partly
what I'm doing in my tour is the
fostering of genuine discourse but I
don't think that says political I don't
think of that as a political movement I
think of it as a psychological movement
or yeah or it I don't know our
constitutional principles in the
political domain I would say no they're
outside the political domain because
they're axioms so they're inside some
other domain they're inside a
philosophical domain or a theological
domain and I think a discussion that's
associated with proper political process
isn't a political discussion I think
it's a meta political disk so would be
what a better way to ask the question
then be do we just need a political
party or a political group or a
politician or whatever to just pick up
on this and then incorporate it so that
it's not a movement in and of itself
interesting we're saying well I mean I
went and talked to what's the name of
that group turning-point America I went
to talk to her yeah Turning Point USA I
went and talked to their women's meeting
they had about 1,200 women down in we
were in Delos and one of the things I
recommended to them was that instead of
concentrating on the content of their
ideology because their branding
themselves in some sense as a
conservative movement that they devote
themselves to educating themselves as
much as they possibly can because
they're going to produce a much bigger
impact by becoming better individuals
than they are by promoting conservative
doctrine that's what it looks like to me
even though there's some utility and
promoting conservative doctrine on the
campuses at least as a counterbalance to
the overwhelming preponderance of
radical leftist thinking mm-hmm but I
don't think the fundamental movement
necessarily necessary here is political
because I think the political is
actually part of the problem so that's
that's how it looks to me all right I
think we're the advanced group set to
sent to take a hill for a healthy
political discourse that follows us yeah
that's hopefully doubt that when you
know Turning Point USA you know I was
shocked that Charlie Kirk intended
Candice Owens reach
that to me is like you do understand who
I am right and I'm very confused by it
because I find that a lot of the
rhetoric that comes out of that
absolutely unpalatable and the private
discourse is much more sympathetic much
more understanding I think that the
political ads a lack of sophistication
actually on the part of the people who
are doing it but I think we can move
those because just for the record I just
want to say that when they invited me to
speaking gigs Charlie said to me from
day one he said I disagree with you on a
ton of stuff but I want to invite you
here to speak yeah and I go up there and
I talk about being gay married and
pro-choice and penalty and all of these
things and they give me a standing
ovation you know yeah yeah but then the
problem is is that nobody can figure out
why I'm talking to Candace Owens because
when she's going in red-meat
conservative mode sure I don't recognize
the same person who reached out to me
and you know well I don't think it is
the same person exactly I think that
there's a fractionation there as well I
know that because of the niche and the
idea is is that there is not yet a niche
this came up with Douglas Murray it's a
super important point in general people
are in a restriction astute on
immigration and they want more
protectionism with respect to trade and
the question like let's take within
immigration is why is it and that no
politician finds it easy to exploit this
without going completely far right or
completely open borders like either it's
ethno-nationalism or it's all people are
equal why should we discriminate from
people in any other country and the
sensible positions are uninhabitable so
the question is why yes
and so the claim that I'm making is you
have to really know your stuff at the
moment if you're going to hold a
position like we cannot be using a
phobic we have to be somewhat
restriction astre cannot close the
borders immigration I particularly want
to put your finger on it you have to
know your stuff to hold that position
but you shouldn't have to know it at
this level I mean in other words the
work I had to do to figure out what the
hell happened with technical and
scientific immigration was a hidden
study from 1986 that nobody outside in
the outside world knew about nobody can
devote two years of their life
generically in order to figure these
things out so the problem
is we have to actually take out the
ground for the middle get rid of the
crazies on both ends and have an idea
that fundamentally or at least stop the
crazies from taking out the reasonable
people that's the issue well I don't we
are just stopping the crazies that's
like well probably not because they're
always there but getting their hands
from around the necks of the people who
are sensible would be a useful at least
intermediary stop I have learned
painfully that I have more in common
with what would now be considered
center-right than I do with radical left
yeah and so this idea of reaching across
the aisle and saying you you take out
your trash I'll take out mine
yeah right is a very important move that
is not happening
and so that's but that's one of the
things that's weird about the the canvas
Owen
Charlie Kirk situation is like when I
went to the Aspen ideas festival the
people who invited me there
I wouldn't say were they're not
canonical members of the commentariat
there are people who are feeling
tremendous pressure and that's partly
why they invited me and I did get
invited but and then I discussed the
things that I was discussing but I
wouldn't say that I felt welcome there
at all and so one of the things that's
weird about going to talk to these
conservative groups is like I went down
to Delos and I talked to these women and
I like I didn't give a conservative talk
right I gave this sort of talk that I'm
having right now and but they were they
were conservative but at the same time
they were actually listening to what I
was saying and they were receptive to it
and so then when I go to the talk to the
leftist types it's like that that
they're ideologically possessed let's
say in the same manner but they're not
open at all okay but but I experienced
something slightly different i I see
exactly this I'm more welcome in
center-right circles than I am in even
center-left circles because of the
contamination has gotten much farther
from from the extreme into the center on
the left but there's still this other
thing like you know I hear the word Lib
[ __ ] yeah and I just like oh for
Christ's sake really hmm you know oh you
want to enslave everybody oh you're
monster turned on you and I just think
okay this is some pre-programmed set of
moves and you know in your comments
there is much more of this stuff than
I'm used to in other people's comments
secular something about it cuz they're
not no no but I'm saying something about
your audience yeah that somewhere in
your evolution you have to watch the
fact that there is this increase in the
incivility on the right and you know I
focus my energy on the left because it's
my responsibility I don't think the
right is my responsibility but well
these people are struggling with the
same problem you laid out at the
beginning though it's like we can we can
make the case for civility and should
but but you say well the civility only
goes so far till you defend yourself
it's like yeah well that's a big problem
it's like exactly how far does it go and
then how do you defend yourself and when
you're defending yourself what
strategies to use now one of the things
I learned and I talked about this with
Dave last night and it's something I
think that we should think about as
members of this loose group is that you
you don't defend yourself more than is
absolutely necessary
right it's a minimal necessary force
doctorate is the correct one and so Lib
[ __ ] and that sort of thing could
probably be shelved as ineffective and
counterproductive right although part of
the reason that it's coming up at least
in part is in an attempt to be
ineffective and counterproductive it's
offensive and stupid
well okay week that's fine that's fine
that's fine but but my point is it's
actually it's actually technically
complicated it's like it's not that easy
to mount an effective defense that isn't
simultaneously an attack you have to be
very like I want to push you back just
far enough so you're back but no farther
it's like and I mean that's worked out
in my situation so far because generally
when I've been attacked publicly in the
press even in interviews right I've been
able to use minimal necessary force and
every time that's happened it's worked
and so one of the things I would
recommend and this would be to your
listeners and viewers and props to mine
as well perhaps to yours is that don't
push back any harder than you have to
right because it's it gets rapidly come
do it are balanced fashion my typical
thing is if somebody's going to come on
gangbusters and I give them three
opportunities or so to cut it out and
they refuse to it you know yeah I like
the rule of three a lot of like you can
tell I see Mac them to the curb and then
I offer them a hand up right then the
question is okay you're gonna bite the
hand up then then we have a further
problem because now you're just on some
sort of unbounded descent into hell and
i mighta didn't following you there but
I think you know that what's really
going on and this is the the the the
hardest point to make is that we need to
new sort of hermaphroditic parties that
combine elements of right and left that
don't look like the terrible situation
that we inherited from the baby boomers
no offense sir where for a very long
period of time we've been under one
group group set of ideas that are
crashing and burning and whatever is a
new thing that replaces right and the
new thing that replaces left is is going
to have combinations of these things and
so for example maybe situation specific
well this is the thing I make more
differentiated every smart person I know
is pro-market the key question is do you
believe that the market should be
allowed to do everything like you get
these very purist things I am the I'm an
iron Randy and I'm a guaranteed
free-market ear but then you put things
in front of them and you say look should
physics be allowed to sign a licensing
deal where we charge you for everything
we've created like the semiconductor you
know or the communications equipment
that you that you use to run your life
because if you want to talk to me one
more time about tax dollars for science
I'm gonna point out to you that you're
breaking a compact that we had that you
were gonna support us and we weren't
going to charge we charge you because we
charge you we're gonna be the ones in
with the yachts and the fourth homes and
you're gonna be able to to pay your
physics bill you know and the point of
this is when you Welch on a contract and
you start to say no no it's the market
well guess what you know public goods
are part of markets and they're very
valuable and they're hard to get anyone
to pay for them and so you have to use
some amount of violence right vaporous
theory is that a government is a
monopoly on violence and that's why it
exists when you have these very pure
ideological positions
not tutored by reality or deeper theory
they are very very difficult to dislodge
people from now because you are taking a
ton of risk as a small business owner
you are going to be predisposed towards
a libertarian mindset because you're not
only making money from your hard work
you're making money from the fact that
you're taking on huge amounts of risk
and when people don't identify risk
management as a source of inequality
we've got a problem on the other hand
there are a ton of people I know in New
York we're making money hand over fist
by extracting it through rent-seeking by
putting themselves as the toll
collectors so that everybody who's got
to do business has to pay them off in
some sort of legalized form of
corruption and those people I
fundamentally think we should have
clawed back their property on Long
Island and come up with clawback
National Seashore when we bailed them
out in the you know Great Recession and
collapsed in 2008 now well maybe we'll
get lucky and you know and I'm thinking
that that this is a possibility is that
these increasingly long form
opportunities for communication in the
rise of podcasts and the rise of
audiobooks and all of that is going to
produce our more educated and committed
electorate and they will be
sophisticated enough to start to sort
out these problems without recourse to
these ideological with less recourse to
these ideological over social still
fighting us to Jordan they're still
they're still not coming I mean the
number of people I know who are
privately aware of me and publicly show
no awareness of what I'm talking about
hmm actually the same thing for you well
it's a range of tilting it still fast
man it was much more for you I mean
because I think by break mug someone has
to get there first
no no what yeah and you broke through
with the book and it was your doing a
different thing than anybody else in
this network is doing but my point would
be that they had to contend with you
because they had a mystery which is why
is there a what number one bestseller by
somebody who's I mean how do we explain
any amount of this what you Dave it's
just that I come to unveil my angry
young white man for words that those
aren't the people who are buying well
those the funny you know and I started
taking pictures with all of the people
of color and the
talks are up to about 40% women now and
these at least at least yeah the age the
one thing I do see though is that lots
of men come alone but very few women
come alone but it's it's about 40% women
now and I tell you about the group of
grandmothers that I met no no about a
week or two ago I forget what city it
was and there was this group of
grandmother they get together and it was
there was about nine or ten of them and
all in their 60s and 70s and they they
all loved you and it was like oh you
know the drawers in September oh then
you'll get all the great you know one
one kid came up to me one of your talks
and I said you know he's start talking
about how important it was that you were
there and I said well what is this done
for your life he says what hasn't it
done for my life he says you know I was
I was at home
smoking weed masturbating too much
playing video games and you know six
months later I've got a job a fiancee
you know you know I think he had some
gal who was not interested in because of
his situation but liked him yeah it
turned his life around yeah and I
thought this is partly what's so
incredibly fun about these events is
that people just tell that story over
and over it's so fun because they come
up to me and they say look here's six
months ago I was having all these
troubles and and sometimes it's serious
I was suicidal and you buddy what was
really affect what really affected me
about this conversation was nothing
about this guy said loser and what what
it told me is is that some of the
difficulties we've had in our markets
particularly after post 2008 like there
was this thing that worked less and less
well over time and people who were
college educated who were hard-working
who were creative we're still living at
home with their parents and I think it's
an added kick it's like you know when do
you hit the nitrous oxide in order to
get the car to zoom into hyperspace I
think you know I before I ever met you I
had this stick about the world uncle
shortage that fundamentally we needed a
class of uncles and also aunts who
aren't exactly parents to put a cigar in
your mouth in a single malt in your hand
and say listen kid this is how the world
actually works
get the hell out there and master it
yeah don't don't don't you bucco me but
the key issue is is that I think you
became the one man answer to the world
uncle shortage and I think it's
important at some point to deepen the
offering because there are many
different kinds like fundamentally I
need to not focus on cleaning my room
because I'm a messy room guy and I need
to get my physics out and I need to do
certain sorts of things you know to get
my life in order that are different
they're not doing anything you could
start by cleaning your room no no I
didn't mean it's not bad advice oh I
know I know but it's also the case that
we need sane tough funky ants because
there's a lot of bad advice being given
to women hmm and oh well a lot of this
radical stuff on the Left isn't going to
be sorted out by man if it's going to be
sorted out it's gonna be sorted out by
sensible women who put it into it and
I'm hoping that will happen law and just
a sensible women that I am that I've
talked to who would like to do that are
terrify terribly threaded by I'm so glad
you said oh absolutely
I hear that over and over and these are
often women who are in positions of
substantial power you wouldn't think
that they would be who who in either a
fight of this but they are this is this
is what one of these women who will
remain nameless said to me she said I've
never been afraid of men and I said well
what are you afraid of
and we worked through it a little bit
and she said I guess what I'm afraid of
his weak women yes brother
yes what an interesting observation that
fundamentally you know strong people can
say that comment was a little sour yeah
it doesn't have to be like oh yeah what
did you say you know because very often
how many boneheaded comments I make
boneheaded comments you make money if
you if people don't have a chance to
play with ideas and to come back from it
ever if the answer to everything is
you're canceled yes well then then
there's no hope well then you're not and
you're also just not inviting people to
play if the ideas that can't be stupid
in their initial formulations of the
ideas then they don't get to thing right
on the nose sir on that note I want to
take my two uncles out to lunch
and then we will bring in my cousin Ben
Shapiro how does that sound sound good
all right guys so we're gonna do this
second live stream this is going to end
in a second we're gonna do the second
live stream with Ben at one o'clock
Pacific and be nice in the comment
section because that's what your uncle's
want out of you guys alright we'll be
back in a sec
[Music]